[Musica]
perché eravamo lì a giocare a tombola
intorno al tavolo ambo quaterna tombola
una ricordo perchè sono stato io a fare
tombola
non era mai successo prima con la notte
me la ricordo perché intorno alla
mezzanotte circa poco prima abbiamo
tirato fuori tutti il telefono e abbiamo
incominciato a mandare dei messaggi in
giro per il mondo
ricordo quella notte perché era il 31
dicembre del 2019
quella notte ho scoperto dopo nel mondo
in poche ore sono stati inviati 100
miliardi di immagini 100 miliardi di
messaggi di cui 12 erano immaggini 12
miliardi di immagini in pochissime ore
immagini che giravano nell'etere se
rimarrò qui dentro
per darvi un'idea nel medioevo una
persona normale vedeva nell'arco della
sua vita mediamente 13 immagini 13 certo
l'età media era minore qualcuno magari
si spostava un po di più e ne vedeva 15
20 ma noi in poche ore potenzialmente
abbiamo potuto vedere 12 miliardi di
immagini che vagavano nell'etere dello
spazio e finivano dentro lo schermo di
questo telefono e allora mi sono fatto
una domanda che cos'è uno schermo uno
schermo è un luogo un posto una
superficie uno spazio su cui noi
possiamo proiettare su cui noi possiamo
vedere delle immagini questo è uno
schermo quello è uno schermo il computer
il televisore di casa vostra e uno
schermo
abbiamo sempre avuto bisogno di schermi
sempre di finestre affacciate su un
mondo parallelo dove guardare dove
osservare una realtà altra rispetto a
quella che
viviamo 20.000 anni fa lo schermo erano
le grotte di lasko era lì che l'uomo
proiettava tutto quello che vedeva non
c'era molto da vedere c'erano animali
animali che l'uomo cacciava animali che
l'uomo proiettava sulle pareti in
maniera bidimensionale e queste immagini
tenevano insieme la comunità aggregavano
e l'uomo l'uomo si sentiva meno solo
l'uomo aveva meno paura
e poi sono passati millennio sono sorte
nuove civiltà
ognuno aveva bisogno di immagini e alle
immagini degli animali se ne sono
aggiunte altre immagini di figure
bidimensionali immagini in cui la
comunità si identificava immagini che
aggregavano che mettevano ordine al
disordine e così l'uomo aveva meno paura
l'uomo si sentiva meno solo poi passano
i secoli passano i millenni passa del
tempo ea padova in una piccola cappella
privata un italiano di nome giotto in
mente il cinema in 3d
quelle immagini non sono più di
dimensionali sono tridimensionali
occupano uno spazio tridimensionale
hanno un corpo hanno dei sentimenti come
i nostri vestono quasi come noi e noi ci
identifichiamo con loro sono segni
simboli immagini cristiane che tengono
insieme alla comunità che aggregano
fanno sì che l'uomo abbia meno paura che
l'uomo si senta meno solo e poi passa
ancora del tempo non molto per la verità
passo un secolo ne passa un altro e ci
sono tre professionisti che mettono a
punto quella tecnologia leonardo da
vinci a milano
michelangelo buonarroti e raffaello
sanzio entrambi a roma sono loro che
proiettano sui muri delle basiliche
queste immagini
questi segni questi simboli cristiani
che tengono insieme sono attori
protagonisti e comparse ma sono immagini
che tengono insieme alla comunità che
aggregano che mettono ordine al
disordine fanno sì che l'uomo adesso
un po meno paura che l'uomo si senta
meno solo
passano i secoli e l'uomo inventa altri
schermi inventa il cinema e poi il
cinema entra in casa nostra e l'uomo
inventa la televisione milioni milioni
di immagini che tengono insieme che ci
tengono incollati davanti a questo
schermo e creano aggregazione e fanno sì
che abbiamo meno paura che ci sentiamo
meno soli
ma che cosa vuol dire avere meno paura
il sociologo peter berger dice che
quello che teme di più l'uomo la paura
ultima non è il male ma è il caos
il caos il caos inteso come mancanza di
orientamento il caos inteso come
disordine il caos inteso come tumulto di
avvenimenti privi di interpretazione ma
l'uomo non può fare a meno di
interpretare il mondo
l'uomo diceva albert camus ha bisogno di
un mondo che possa che si possa spiegare
anche con cattive ragioni pur che gli
sia familiare anche con cattive ragioni
pur che gli sia familiare ea mettere
ordine al disordine a mettere ordine in
questa mancanza di orientamento ci pensa
la cultura la cultura non è vero dizione
la cultura è un'altra cosa
la cultura secondo l'antropologo edward
barber taylor è quell'insieme complesso
che include il sapere le credenze l'arte
la morale di diritto il costume e ogni
altra competenza e abitudine acquisita
dall uomo in quanto membro della società
la cultura come antidoto al caos la
cultura come mondo in contrapposizione
alla natura la cultura come il luogo del
simbolico
simbolico simbolo una bella parola
deriva dal greco sim ballo significa
tenere insieme il simbolo e ciò che
tiene insieme la comunità e l'arte per
molti secoli si è occupata di questo
l'arte era il luogo del simbolico e i
muri delle grotte di lasko le basiliche
che abbiamo in italia erano quelli
luoghi su cui il simbolo trovava una
collocazione
poi oggi questo è il luogo
questi sono i nuovi schermi 12 miliardi
di immagini in poche ore saranno troppe
ma non saranno troppe noi dobbiamo
mettere ordine al disordine con il
simbolo e qui ne passano 12 miliardi
beh questa domanda prima di me se l'era
fatta qualcun altro perché gli artisti
sugli artisti quando si parla di
immagini
beh sono sempre un po più avanti
rispetto a noi è il loro mestiere e
allora a 60 anni fa un artista di milano
meglio era argentino ma aveva studiato a
milano che si chiamava lucio fontana
aveva tagliato una tela il taglio di
fontana e tutti ancora oggi a dire ma
quella non è arte ma quella è
provocazione perché nel mondo dell'arte
contemporanea
quando non sai cos'è allora provocazione
dice ma questa cosa la so fare pure io
in realtà la luce fontana prima di fare
questa tela quando aveva 29 anni un po
per esercitarsi studiava all'accademia
di belle arti di brera a milano aveva
fatto questa qui una madonna col bambino
ma non che glielo avesse chiesto a
qualcuno perché era finita l'epoca in
cui qualcuno chiedeva una madonna col
bambino non so voi l'ultima volta che
avete chiesto una madonna col bambino
eppure questo bisogno c'è solo che oggi
la madonna col bambino o le storie
legate alla passione o alla vergine le
vediamo in televisione le vediamo al
cinema
nessuno le chiede più agli artisti e
allora fontana taglia una tela non per
provocare ma per indicare una strada
perché è consapevole che quel mondo lì
il mondo della tela bianca l'epoca della
tela bianca è tramontato perché adesso
le immagini viaggiano nello spazio e
finiscono dentro casa nostra
dentro lo schermo del televisore di casa
nostra e oggi qui dentro che anche se
non siamo casa ce lo portiamo dietro 12
miliardi di immagini ma non saranno
troppe ma non c'è troppo disordine qui
dentro la mia mente non è in grado di
gestire tutto questo c'è troppo per
piacere io chiedo per piacere ridateci
gli artisti e ridateci l'arte fate in
modo che si torni a mettere un segno su
quella tela bianca perché anche se
l'epoca della tela bianca è terminata si
può comunque continuare a produrre arte
anche un altro modo l'arte non è solo la
tela bianca
l'arte questo palco
l'arte o un prato verde l'arte qualsiasi
luogo in cui si possa lasciare un segno
anche quando questo segno sembra
insignificante sembra incomprensibile
anche quando questo segno non
rappresenta nulla è pur sempre un segno
un segno su quella ipotetica tela bianca
e questo segno ci serve a mettere ordine
al disordine l'arte non serve solo a
produrre bellezza siamo pieni di
bellezza c'è troppa bellezza in giro
questo telefono è bello quella
telecamera e bella questi riflettori
sono belle automobili sono belle basta
saperle guardare l'arte non è solo una
produzione di bellezza o meglio non è
più una produzione di bellezza e anche
da molto tempo
basta poco basta un segno su quella tela
bianca è allora quella tela un po meno
bianca e allora torniamo a dare senso e
allora alla domanda che cos'è l'arte a
che cosa serve l'arte bene io propongo
di rispondere che l'arte non è solo una
produzione di bellezza ma l'arte serve a
qualche cosa di più l'arte può servire
per trasformare il caos primordiale in
un grande gesto d'amore
[Applauso]